[Music]
are you shopping for a gift
feda browsing for me so sizing is a
little limited here in the store but you
could probably find your size online I
have a crazy idea let's be honest for a
minute no matter how many times we hear
it's what's on the inside that matters
women know deep down it's what's on the
outside that the whole world judges okay
I'm just like dealing with low
self-esteem and like I want to punch you
right in your dumb face right now do you
have every rib that I have I've been on
all of these sites
no one even looks at the profiles they
only care about the picture and I'm sick
of it
I've always wondered what it feels like
to be just undeniably pretty
okay you hit your head pretty hard
[Music]
Dixit day I see you lit up I know you
don't recognize me as me you go use it's
me Renee what's happening Oh full spin
that's that's really clever let's go
what's your number
give me your phone when you give you my
number are you still talking to me
chicken out now some iowa's you this
would be quite a large promotion for you
what do you call this exactly I get it
and yes modeling is an option for me
it's not who I am things have really
changed for me you just have all the
clothes in the world I think a lot of
people including this thing that really
makes them awesome and you're not like
that
DJ hit
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
submission videos for me I should be out
you might wanna make deep of what's to
come
I don't know if you know it sneak peek
means you're completely
[Music]